for your signature in a valley below the
rumataka mountains the electorate of New
Zealand's new prime minister or chippy
as he's known here in Upper Hutt's High
Street signs of the challenges
confronting him failed businesses Statin
and consumer demand and a feeling that
New Zealand has become a less equal
Society helping what their classes
middle-income people because we seem to
be struggling more than the lower and
higher income people we don't get much
help at all whatsoever Chris Hipkins is
in the news because of the woman he's
replacing Jacinda ardern's last public
engagement as prime minister Testament
to what's been a friendly albeit Swift
transfer of power when jazinder Adam
became prime minister her popularity was
undeniable but a rating slid on a
backlash against covid-19 restrictions
increased food costs Rising mortgages
concerns over crime
and people wanted someone to blame yes I
think she did an absolute fabulous job
over the covert and the shootings and
all that sort of thing but she's just
lost her Moto towards the end
I know what this job takes and I know
that I no longer have enough in the tank
to do it justice last Thursday's
announcement was one that few saw coming
an unusual acknowledgment from a world
leader that she was burnt out vicious
abuse
on the streets and online raised
concerns over her safety she's received
death threats and so is her child
her replacement has called the abuse
abhorrent
the next election will be in less than
nine months which means Hipkins may not
be in the job long especially as opinion
polls show labor now training the
conservative opposition our dernius
leaving office at a time of her choosing
although she'll remain an MP for three
more months and at 42 she still has
plenty of time to ponder a new career
and the one she's left thank you from
the bottom of my heart for the greatest
privilege of my life
Adrian Brown Al Jazeera Wellington